[Music]
today the music video proceeded Aoki's
collab with oh none of them said VPS
that unstoppable pop group excuse me
eg lives Tanner Thomas and went behind
the scenes with the all-asian
cast of the music video it includes Ken
Jong and Jimmy O yang take a look what's
up guys I'm here with Steve Aoki on the
set of his new music video how is it
going today it's going incredible it's
going absolutely incredible we got so
many famous actors and actresses here
from the Asian community all coming
together to really represent the Asian
community the first actor I've reached
out to was Ross Butler and I was like
you know what I want to do this hall
Asian cast for the video will you be the
lead and and he was all up for it
reached out to my sister Devon we've
been waiting to do something together
one of the signs that this was a
successful song was when he called me
and asked me if I'd do it and I actually
said yes do you say no I usually say no
but but this time I was like I actually
thought about it a little bit of
convincing I just didn't want to miss
out could you maybe give us a few words
about Ken Jong's role or Ross Butler's
role in this music video I'm trying to
get to the bottom of what's happening
here I haven't been able to get that
many details
no I you go ahead and watch the video
watch the video
hey wasted on me what is this music
video about well it's about it's a love
song it's a great love song about hey I
know you don't believe in love but you
can waste your non-believing on me can
you tell us about the character that you
play because we're talking to Ben baller
a minute ago he wouldn't give us any
details I know Ken Jong's here he's been
here all day
who do you play in the video uh it's not
like I'm trying to keep it a secret it's
more like I don't know it's just
whatever to tell me to do I just do it
so we'll see I'm trying to get to the
bottom of what this video is about well
you know that's top secret so I can't
really speak on too much about it in
fact I don't even know who I'm playing
or what I'm doing yet in the video but
I'm sure it's a as long as I want
playing the Chinese delivery boy or
something or you know anything has do
with March
some good men so you seriously don't
know what role you're playing I do I
just can't talk they told me I can't
talk about it so you know can you tell
us about your character yeah I play a
waiter who is just is basically I think
he's serving Ross Butler and Devin Aoki
so it's it's kind of the the waiter
characters kind of obsessed with with
Devin and not and not Ross so any kind
of fantasizes that you know what if he
was with her and in the form of like
montages of music video parodies and oh
ma jizz and and it's just so his
imagination just runs runs wild and it's
kind of in many ways kind of like a like
a commentary on like if you know
celebrity culture and you know if and
kind of people who take celebrity like a
little bit too seriously a little bit of
that this is like you know I've done a
couple of music videos but not but not
one where I have to be on point with
lyrics so much so you you know I'm like
studying my script which is the lyric
sheet and trying to sync that up I feel
like that's a spoiler but I'm gonna take
it yeah I mean I guess so I guess I I
don't know maybe I said too much but but
sorry the song has been a huge hit in
the u.s. earning nearly 6 million
streams since its release that less than
a month ago and we're just gonna take
another listen to it so you can really
hear that tune is we had to break easy
live it will be right wanna be some
funny
you treat me like a come on take it to
one fries yeah come eat me and throw me
a bad match
sighs but why
making this way this way and I know
there's no changing your mind
[Music]
[Applause]